[Music]
welcome to the launch of the european
innovation council
i'm mark ferguson and i'm the chair of
the advisory board of the european
innovation council
and we have a star-studded lineup for
you this morning to celebrate this
really important event in europe
but i'm going to commence with a
quotation from rudyard kipling
which i think sums up today's auspicious
occasion
and the quotation is as follows this
is the opening verse of the opening
chapter
of the book of endless possibilities and
i think that sums up where we are today
with the european innovation council so
it's now my great pleasure
to introduce the president of the
european commission
ursula van der laan who will speak to us
and she will be followed
by emmanuel macron the president of
france
commissioned president the floor is
yours
thank you so much and good morning what
a big day i am delighted indeed
to welcome all of you to the launch of
the european
innovation council and we all know
this launch could not come at a better
time
as we will emerge from the pandemic
innovation
will be key for the success of our
digital and our green agenda
and we all know europe is a powerhouse
in science
our new horizon research program is the
largest ever
but we also face a big paradox
we europeans are excellent in making
signs
with money but we're not so good in
making money
out of science and the new european
innovation council is there
to help resolve this paradox
with it put in place
we want to have an ecosystem that gives
entrepreneurs every opportunity to
create a world leading company
with our innovation council we make 10
billion euros
available until 2027
we fund small and medium-sized companies
with high risk
but also with high potential we support
innovative researchers that have ideas
for the next breakthrough technology
and we offer coaching matchmaking
and support them to set up a business
the european innovation council is also
part of our answer
to the equity funding gap in europe
currently many european startups cannot
find the risk capital they need
experts estimate this that this funding
gap
is as large as 70 billion euros
our new eic fund is a good start
it alone brings 3 billion euros to the
table
and with the eic fund the commission is
for the first time investing directly
in startups and smes and this will also
help
attract additional risk capital from the
private sector
because if we want innovative ideas to
make it to the market
we have to support those europeans who
are willing to take risks
there is no time to waste and this is
why today
we don't just cut ribbons
we get down to business and launch the
first calls
over 1.5 billion euros are foreseen
alone for this year
most of this will directly support smes
and startups
half of the finance at least will
support the green deal
digital technologies and health
innovation
and with this the eic fits well
into our overall strategy for the coming
years
we want to come out of this crisis
stronger than before
we want europe to build forward better
more sustainable more digital and more
resilient
we already know that the eic is well
equipped to help
us achieve these goals because its work
didn't start today
since 2018 in a pilot phase
it has already supported over 5000
startups
smes and research projects
159 companies were already selected to
receive venture capital from the
commission
the very first company by the way
was a medical sme core wave
from france core rave
develops innovative heart pumps they
work with
membranes and reduce complications for
patients with heart failure
in january the company received 15
million euros from the european union
and attracted 20 million euros from
private investors
and with this core wave could build up
manufacturing complete tests
and start clinical trials so that soon
patients can benefit from this
innovation
and this is what europe can achieve when
finance meets science
when ideas turn into innovation
and products on the market
ladies and gentlemen 14 years ago
we created the european research council
to support top researchers based on
scientific excellence
the european innovation council we are
create creating today
will be its strong partner to support
breakthrough technology
and scale up disruptive innovation
with the launch of the eic we kind of
complete the research and innovation
landscape
in europe and we also demonstrate
the innovative potential of europe and
the european institutions
and with this i declare europe
open to innovation and i look forward to
many
successes thank you very much for your
attention
[Music]
depending on the s
the late stage
foreign
repair
ecosystem publicly
[Music]
thank you and thank you to the
commission president and to president
macron for those strong words of support
so as you've heard today is the eic
official launch
and the european innovation council has
been in pilot phase
until now and it's been my privilege to
chair
the advisory board of the european
innovation council and i want to give
you some
of the vision from that board the
european
innovation council represents the most
ambitious initiative
that europe has ever undertaken in the
field of innovation
it's a unique european approach to
innovation
it focuses on relevant innovations
conducted in responsible ways
it combines a darpa-like approach to
advanced research
with an accelerator for scala and the
european innovation council will become
a hallmark of innovation excellence
in the same way that the european
research council has become a global
hallmark
of research excellence the european
innovation council
will overcome biases we will overcome
biases against
female entrepreneurs we will overcome
biases
against entrepreneurs from less known
regions of the european union
we will crowd in private investment
private investment in european deep tech
the 10 billion budget of the european
innovation council
aims to crowd in at least 50 billion
from the private sector
those investments are critical to allow
the deep tech
innovative companies to grow and scale
in europe
and the european innovation council was
will act as an
impact fund a fund to translate the
research findings
from researchers in the european
research council or in the missions or
any of the other european programs and
from the national member state programs
translate those deep tech research
innovations
into businesses that can scale and grow
in europe
the european innovation council will
become the investor of choice
for visionary researchers and visionary
entrepreneurs
who want to grow and scale their
businesses in europe
we will be innovation friendly one
innovation community with three
principal instruments
pathfinder transition and accelerator
and tomorrow there is a day dedicated to
potential
applicants to the european innovation
council where you will learn more about
our programs
and be able to ask interactive questions
through slido
so that you can apply to grow and scale
your business
in europe the european innovation
council will be
agile dynamic a really flexible approach
to european commission funding for
innovation
we will work together with corporates we
will crowd in corporates
leveraging not only their financial uh
investments but also their capabilities
in supply chain
sales to create a perfect european
innovation uh community and as the
commission president said
we will address important problems of
digitalization
the green agenda climate change
sustainability
what could be better than finding a
company that can create employment
that can grow the economy that can make
money
and that can do good for the planet at
the same time
nothing could be better and that's the
aim of the european innovation council
and i'm really pleased that this aim is
embodied
uh within the commissioner uh
commissioner mario gabrielle
who is better placed than me to put
forward the vision
of the european innovation council maria
gabrielle is the european commissioner
for innovation
research culture education and youth
and it's my great pleasure now to
introduce her to say a few words about
the european innovation council
commissioner gabrielle thank you
thank you very much uh mark ladies and
gentlemen first of all
i would like to say that yesterday we
are celebrating the birth
of the fully fledged european innovation
council with the first
tranche of eic calls for funding for
deep tech startups in seed stage and
serious a
worth over one and a half billion euros
and i would like to start by thanking
all the people that have made possible
that today the european innovation
council is born
i'm thinking here in my predecessor
carlos moyers
the parliament reporter christian elev
but also in the members of the board
that represent innovation ecosystem as a
whole
as well as the hundreds of experts and
officials that have participated
in the last three years in the ideation
and piloting phases of this new european
endeavor and allow me here to start by
summarizing in few words
what the european innovation council is
it is a major new component of horizon
europe
with its own budget over 10 billion
euros
its own governance with an independent
board of innovators
its own proactive approach to management
with hands-on program managers and with
an
innovative way to support innovators
equity investment by the eic fund
it is designed to provide financial and
ecosystem support
to sea stage and serious aids disruptive
startups
and i would like now to focus on the
three reasons
that made us to set up the eic on the
first
place first the so-called
european innovation paradox that europe
is a world leader in science and
research
but that other regions lead on
innovation
so the eic will build on the amazing
research
base in europe to support disruptive
deep tech and market creation startups
this will be a priority role for the eic
program managers
that will work closely with the european
research council
and with the european institute of
innovation and technology
second the difficulties for european
deep tech startups
to get enough funding for grow deep tech
is considered as the fourth wave of
innovation
and brings the power of combining
software and hardware
to develop the transformational
disruptive innovations that we need
for a fair green and digital pandemic
recovery
we are talking about synthetic biology
advanced materials
photonics quantum computing artificial
intelligence
they are problem oriented and not only
technology driven
and they are purpose-driven innovators
97 of deep tech ventures
contribute to at least one of the un's
sustainable development goals
the european innovation council
accelerator
has already a good track record
of supporting deep tech startups with
successful examples
which are becoming global leaders in
their domains
beyond grants the erc will invest
equity into these companies to finance
their scale up
and to attract other investors to
finance these amazing companies
with around 550 million euros this year
the eic fund will become a top deep deck
early stage investor in europe the third
obstacle
is that the eic will help
innovators overcome the fragmentation of
the ecosystem
more and more locations in europe have
established
world-leading ecosystems in the last
years
from sofia to madrid from varshall to
stockholm
unfortunately the ecosystem is not well
connected at european level
and many regions face the risk to be
left behind
so i'm aware of this need to have
everyone on board
and on equal food and if we really want
to make
fully use of the potential of our
ecosystems we need to address each this
challenge
because the ecosystem is not only
fragmented it is also concentrated
in some big cities and we are missing
women talents
today when we talk about women talent
three quarters of startups in europe are
funded by men
while only eight percent are funded by
all women teams and this lack of
diversity
translates into the low amount of
capital invested into women led
and managed companies creating a vicious
circle
in 2019 92
of all funds raised by the european
venture capital backed companies
went to all male funding teams so
a major endeavor for the eic is to
upgrade the overall
euro european innovation ecosystem
this will be achieved by fully involving
the ecosystem
in all of its activities and decisions
in the world
in all investment decisions creating
networks of corporate and public
procurers
networks of investors in sea stage and
serious a
and by working in partnership with the
european institute of innovation and
technology
the eic and that's my wish will reach
out to find
and attract the untapped innovation
potential
in all our 27 member states as well in
urban
as well in rural areas paying special
attention
to continue increasing the percentage of
women-led
startups in europe so i'm really proud
that again on these issues we have
already results
since i mean commissioner responsible
for eic
just allow me to give an example the
percentage of women led startups
benefiting from eic support has grown
from
8 to 34 while keeping
excellence as the selection criteria and
now we would like
to increase this to close to 50
but besides the direct beneficiaries of
the eic
i think in the whole group of women
innovators
that is why in addition to the women
tech
initiative that i announced earlier this
month
i'm proud today to announce the launch
of the 2021 edition
of the european prize for women
innovators
dedicated to the memory of dr
shimrit perkel finkel who was awarded
the prize in 2019 and has tragically
passed
away earlier this month shimrit was a
brilliant
marine biologist and a visionary
enterpreneur
with this prize we want to create role
models for women
and girls everywhere and inspire the
next generation to follow in their
footsteps
also with the aim of building innovation
ecosystems
i'm announcing today the launch of the
capital of innovation
innovation awards that this year is also
targeting
mid-sized cities we need to ensure that
the new wave of innovation
reaches out to all corners of europe
well the european innovation council
that we are launching today
will definitely change the landscape of
european innovation
and will contribute to the main
political priorities of the eu
first we want that the eic has an
immediate
impact on the pandemic recovery by
changing the application process
into an agile and shorter process as of
today
startups can apply at any time to the
eic accelerator
with a simple video pitch some slides
and a short form
eic experts will evaluate their idea
immediately and provide feedback within
a few weeks
asking for a full proposal in june
this means that we'll be able to sign
the first runs in early autumn
the process for providing equity has
also been streamlined
and the investment committee will
participate in the interviews
as well to speed the equity part of the
support
and our goal is that grant and equity
are provided with a very small
difference of time
second the eic is also part of our
europeans ambitions on the brain deal
and digitization
in the first tic calls that are being
announced today
there is at least 300 million euros
earmarked for green deal technologies
and startups
as well as at least 150 million euros
for strategic digital technologies
and finally through investing in deep
tech startups
the eic will also safeguard future
european technological sovereignty we
have seen the problems that arise
when europe is depending on others for
critical technologies
and the eic will invest in emerging
technologies and companies
to make sure we have european technology
champions
and that we are not reliant or dependent
on others
so in conclusion the launch of the
european innovation casio
is definitely one of the priorities for
all of us and i'm really extremely proud
of
what has been achieved but it is also
the starting
point for a broader reform of the
european innovation policy
over the coming months we'll be working
together
with the innovation community with all
our stakeholders
to see how we can have a real
pan-european innovation ecosystem
for the benefit of these new breed of
innovators
that will be an ambitious endeavor but
the creation of the eic
demonstrates that europe can set a high
ambition for innovation
so let me finish by calling on the whole
innovation community across
europe and beyond put for your forward
your best ideas as proposals to the
european innovation council
invest with us in a new generation of
european innovative champions
help us unlock the talent across all of
europe's regions
and from women innovators thank you very
much for your attention
thank you and thank you commissioner
very much indeed so the european
innovation council is being launched
today around europe
and over a hundred leading innovators
researchers and investors have come
forward to be eic
champions so let's hear from some of
[Music]
them
[Music]
are you ready if you're an entrepreneur
if you're an innovator if you have
vision and ambition
and if you firmly believe that your
innovation has the potential to make a
positive impact and to compete on a
global scale
then you must seize this opportunity
aic a new horizon program offers
unprecedented chance for the scientists
to bring their technologies
to the market and help society to deal
with the biggest
issues we have today check in the eic
check the programs see what means are
there
for you what means are there to
translate your ideas into something
practice okay we as society
will be waiting for that
together with co-investors from the
private market we're just adding
a lot of funding into an area where
companies
with disruptive technologies from the
deep tech medtech biotech sector
renewable energies
if you're a deep tech startup or an
innovative research team looking to get
your idea
off the ground i encourage you to apply
for one of the many different
opportunities it also enhances the
european innovation ecosystem through
partnership
with the european institute of
innovation and technology
the european research council and
national regional agencies and ecosystem
builders
and also we'll be very happy to
syndicate with
other investors with other venture
capitalists
for promising financing rounds
into deep tech startups in european
companies thanks to the eic european
innovators don't need to automatically
go to silicon valley any longer
[Music]
with over 10 billion euros to invest in
breakthrough
technologies and game-changing
innovations it contributes to the green
deal and economic recovery package in
europe
each startup can compete literally
compete
for up to 17.5 million euros
in non-dilutive grants and patient
capital
in order to scale so that we can truly
start up europe and scale up europe
[Music]
eac shares funds but also mentorship
of coaches that help to assess the
business feasibility
and market opportunity
[Music]
eic has a strong focus on diversity
gender and inclusion which is built into
its very dna
from the strategic level down to
hands-on kpis
i particularly encourage women
innovators to sign up
so do researchers entrepreneurs smes
corporates we should celebrate this is
happening
just now
[Music]
so it's now my great pleasure to
introduce christian
aylor who is a member of the european
parliament mr ehler was a very early
supporter of the eic when the idea was
first launched
he played a really critical role in the
legislation as the lead rapper tour
in the european parliament for the
horizon europe-specific programme
and that program sets out how the eic
will be implemented
mr ehler we're very grateful for your
contributions in the parliament
and i would now like to give you the
floor
thank you mark um and thank you for the
opportunity to look a little bit
back because we are very lucky that we
have two
had two commissioners in a row actually
having the marriage to establish the eic
but i would like to salute
for a moment
when in early 2015 over lunch he told me
about this project i was hesitating
for a moment pretty much saying we have
to be brave
and when he said it's not a top-down
project i want to reach out to the
stakeholders it should be developed with
a new crowd of
entrepreneurs younger people sometimes
dropouts of universities
entrepreneurs literally not having
anything to do with the traditional
setting of
research funding i said wow what what a
journey to go
this was not a plan top down this was a
commissioner
open to talk to a new generation a new
breed of innovators
and if you read literally
the the cooking recept for the eic
you can sense there had been questions
even resistance i mean i will remember
when the first time
journalists reflecting that they had
been desperately playing with the
acronyms of the european research
program saying
research boss wants to work the erc
magic on
innovation and then followed by an
article
raising all skepticism you could imagine
and even in an administration if you you
be honest if you're a commissioner
and you tell them about a plan to have
an eic
with a continuous evaluation of the
performance
and the agility and speed require
acting portfolio management including
reallocation of resources strengthening
or weakening of individual budgets
or even terminating projects new
executive
agency and program managers which need
the independence to make clear choices
change direction
shift resources fast track to research
and innovation projects
bottom up calls shorter time to grant
support provided only by small
collaborate consortium composed
of over just a few different and
independent eligible legal entities
i mean let's be realistic what a
nightmare for the traditional research
administrations
and so i would like to salute the
bravery of the commission
i like to salute the bravery of carlos
moyers individually
and i want to express the gratitude of
the parliament but also the backing of
the parliament for this eic
we want you to be brave we
wouldn't say we want you to lose money
but we encourage you
not to fear budget control procedures
legal procedures we want to be flexible
we want
that you take risk and we are willing to
follow that path that it has an
experimental component still
and you want we want you to come us and
then we have to change the product to
some extent
and we want to see your success but you
will give you
any kind of backing for this new
flexible instrument
and i think um the the parliament will
be the place and had been the place
also in terms of the budget because
let's be realistic
that had been seen as a cannibalization
of traditional
research money which is not true and
let's be honest if that is a success
project we have to talk about money
because the 10 billion sounds much but
in perspective we need even more money
this is a thirsty new crowd but it will
be a
successful new crowd so thank you very
much for all your efforts i would really
like to thank maria gabriel
to putting that through a difficult
budget procedure
i'd like to thank the research ministers
because in the end
they became brave i like to thank
president macron because
without the help on the presidential
level that would never have happened
and i would like to remind that this
also shows that the ec the european
commission the european project is still
flexible is reaching out to new growth
crowds and it's fast enough to deliver
because we delivered it
in one term so it's a wonderful day
and i would like to thank my old friend
carlos moyadesh thank you very much
thank you very much indeed mr ayla for
those kind words and for the strong
support and indeed i echo
uh the thanks to uh both commissioner
gabrielle and the commissioner modis uh
for their support
it's now my pleasure to introduce uh
manuel haytor the minister for science
technology and higher education
in the government of portugal to present
the views
from the council mr haytor has been
minister since 2015
he's contributed to the political debate
on the eic
and the negotiations on horizon europe
and he currently chairs the
competitiveness council
for the portuguese presidency of the
european commission which has been
launching
uh horizon europe so i now give the
floor to minister manuel haytor
good morning to everyone we should be
very proud
to launch today the european innovation
council
most of us do remember the discussion
over
the last two to three years about
the issue of innovation and how
could we gain from the unique experience
throughout europe of the european
research council
in a similar initiative towards
innovation and let me acknowledge all of
those that have contributed
for this major initiative within
horizon europe actually horizon europe
has just been approved
we launched it on on the 2nd of february
and i'm sure that it will provide
a number of breakthrough initiatives
throughout europe overall
science creates markets science
yields we know very well from
the pandemic crisis we live on but also
the development of um economic
activities of
eiger added value do create and do have
new scientific problems and this
continuous
interaction between science and the
markets the markets
in science are today particularly
critical
to be engaged through new stakeholders
where startups and small
firms small small in business
um are particularly critical in an
european landscape
together with research organizations
in large firms and government and on
government
organizations so the role of
smes and in particular science based
um startups has been
particularly relevant to out to the
world and also in europe
and the relevance of the european
innovation council
is particularly is particularly
concerned
with a market failure very well
identified in europe
to facilitate the growth of these
startups actually we have identified
in many european countries and the
commission
over the years the gap
particularly in defending schemes
not only in the seeding phase but above
all in the growth
process of startups in the european
innovation council
as this mission to stimulate to
facilitate
and to complement under other funding
schemes particularly
now oriented towards a new stimulus
to the growth of small and medium
enterprises
with a science base and these are
breakthroughs
throughout the entire landscape
for example um in the electrification
area we know today that advanced
advancements in science but also needs
in the markets towards the
electrification of mobility
will require a new generation of solid
states
cells particularly lithium cells which
will depends
among many other issues on the atomic
deposition
of nanoparticles this is an area
is in where emerging smes
are being large we have also ads
during the pandemic the the
the creation of vaccines particularly
based on new technologies
like the dna and biontec together with
pfizer is a clear example of the growth
of a small european startup
which with a science-based is evolving
towards the benefit of population
at large examples are
various and very diversified throughout
every single european regime and again
european innovation council was created
within a rising
europe with an earthquake budget to
facilitate the growth
of companies throughout europe and
throughout
europe easing is important because we
have understood
that european science policy must be
inclusive
together with an innovation strategy
which will facilitate investigate more
and more
the enlargement of europe in particular
the engagement of every single european
regime
in our common goal of creating always a
better future
with more knowledge and these do require
about our innovation capacity so we
should be proud
by launching the european innovation
council and to facilitate a new stimulus
to the growth of small
companies and in particular science
based
startups throughout europe thank you
very much
thank you very much indeed minister
haytor now i mentioned earlier it was my
privilege to chair the board of the
european innovation
uh council the advisory board and that's
a group of wonderful people of of
innovators of corporates of investors
and so on
and in line with our innovative emphasis
way of working
we're now going to have a speed dating
session in this speed dating session
you'll see exchanges
around three of the key objectives for
the eic
to build great businesses from
breakthrough science to change the
landscape on deep tech investment in
europe
and to build ecosystems for the
transition to a green and digital
economy and those reflect
the ambitions of the board of the
european innovation council and we've
issued today a statement
which you can see on the eic website
each of these speed dating sessions will
match a member of the european
innovation council advisory board
with other innovators investors and
researchers and i'll have a
distinguished moderator
and after the final session the
moderator of that session
jean-airy pk the director general for
research and innovation
in the european commission we'll provide
a few closing words
so overnight to the speed dating
sessions
what do you see
a little spark slowly growing bigger
lighting up the dark imagine what it
could be
[Music]
what do you see a robot that feels
sustainable fiber or software that
captures the world in 3d
wood and wind turbines transparent solar
panels
reinventing the way we use our energy
a tiny idea so crazy
it's hard to believe an invention with
the intention to change the world
drastically
it's something we would love to see
so tell us what you need
to reimagine to reinvent the world
we can give you a place where unicorns
are born you can chase your dreams
helping hands machinery bigger plans or
just
a chance to show the world something
they haven't seen
so what do you see
[Music]
hello everyone welcome it's great to be
here today discussing how to build
businesses from breakthrough science
as we all know many if not most of the
discoveries that the foundations for
future innovations are developed within
the academic community
so it is therefore very important that
research matures to the point
where it can deliver a benefit to
society
both in terms of technological
development and economic growth
the launch of the new european
innovation council eic
with a budget of 10 billion euros for
the period of 2021 to 2027
aims to nurture promising ideas and
technology from discovery to invention
to innovation
so-called spinouts the creation of
businesses that are born out of academic
research
will be supported by a number of
different eic programs
the pathfinder program will support
high-risk projects with a low
technology readiness level where
emerging technologies meet
groundbreaking science
otherwise known as deep tech this is
where futuristic ideas with real
potential are created many of which will
begin their journey towards market
impact
through the eic transition program and
activities
the eic accelerators support startups
and companies bringing deep tech
innovations to market
and a major part of this is the eic fund
which will make direct equity
investments in eic supported companies
today we've gathered an impressive set
of panelists who have experienced this
journey first hand
from creating fundamental scientific
discoveries
to innovations and commercializations
firsthand
first of all we have the pleasure of dr
igmar whose phd thesis in 2000
led to the discovery of rna vaccines and
the founding of the company curvac
whose anti covered 19 vaccine could be
available later this year
most likely around may ingmar is a
member of the eic pilot advisory board
and has helped design the eic programs
that are launching today
ingram nice to have you um when and how
did you realize that you wanted to spin
out of academia and build a business out
of your scientific discoveries
it's a very good question it's 20 years
back so we
write the year 2000 and well i was
thrilled by my phd work
uh where i spotted that rna can be a new
kind of drug um and i saw a revolution
in drug development already when i did
this
experiments and first of all i i didn't
want to found a company
i wanted to go far my industry i have a
farmer job like everybody in my lab
so i was forced to found because nobody
was taking over my
idea so then i had to do it by myself so
i had to switch
my whole things and there was a really
good um
support from uh the state of bad
wittenberg
where we get a fund a half position
as we had already in the phd work and uh
we could use this half position
to found our company so we had a two
years fund in this two years they were
very
this was very important for us because
we had to gather all the results and we
had willing to try to get vcs on board
and this kind of things and it was a
kind of test run
whether we are able to for um to succeed
here
um which was good so we could use the
same laboratories we are used to
the university rooms we were able to
create our own business there this was
very helpful to us
interesting thank you and what were the
key obstacles
and incentives you found along that
journey and are these eic programs
addressing those
i think it's very important to create a
network from the very beginning
um to have experts who can guide you
and lots of questions you have so many
questions not only on a technical basis
also how to gather money how to get
enough money how to
intensify people how to fascinate people
to follow you
and what are the right people for your
team because it's team building it's all
about a team it's nothing about the
founder itself he has to find the right
team
because founder can't do anything and
and this is very important
so the network is the most important
thing in the beginning
that's great thank you very much okay
we're also joined by sylvia scaglioni
who's the chief research officer and
president of company react for life
which produces bioreactors for
regenerative medicine and cancer
research
she's also coordinating the fvt open
project b2b which is a predecessor
of the eic pathfinder program sylvia i'd
like to get your perspective
since you're another example of an
academic research researcher who's
become an entrepreneur
what motivated you to take that journey
yes as a biomedical engineer
my passion has always been to do
something
that could generate a benefit for
citizen
and for the society and therefore my
my wish is to translate the basic
research
in in a product that could be reliable
first of all
but also usable and accessible by anyone
and for this reason four years ago i
funded the react for life
which is an innovative company that has
the aim
to provide technological solutions like
micro physiological systems resembling
in vitro the human body
to accelerate the disease knowledge
and boost the personalized medicine
in in this company we have already
concluded
interesting validations such
as in the field of cancer disease
that may accelerate the personalized
medicine
and the different pharma are already
some of our customers
and this me phase one instrument that we
have won
during the eic pilot allowed
to better define our business model
and the market positioning also thanks
to the taylor
custom made coaching that
the eu provided to us
great thanks silvia and since you also
coordinate the fvt open project
let me ask you how horizon 2020 funding
has enabled you to bring
technology a step closer to
commercialization
yes the fat project that i'm
coordinating
it's really an amazing high-risk
collaborative
disruptive research it lasted four years
and it has received about four million
of funding
the fed project allows to advance
in the integration of different
disruptive technologies
like organized bioprinting
microphysiological systems
finally generating a prototype that we
have the option
to validate as a proofer concept within
the fat
project but these disruptive innovations
need funding and time to
generate and progress towards the market
and due to their intrinsic risk-ness
it's really difficult to receive funds
and this is the reason of why the eic
pathfinder allowed to us to um
to go ahead towards the market and i
believe that the
outcome of the fed project will become
the product the prototype at the end of
the project
more attractive also for the vc funding
with the final aim to reach the market
thank you you mentioned the amount of
time taken to reach the market
so that's probably a good time to bring
in our final panelist
louis de lis who's the ceo of corewave a
french company producing blood pumps
based on a nature mimicking wave
membrane technology
core wave was one of the first companies
to receive investment from the eic fund
of 15 million euros as part of a 35
million funding round
louis as sylvia just mentioned it can
take a really long time for deep tech
startups to bring their innovations to
market
particularly in the medical technology
field which is complicated by
things like regulation and approval
processes which vary
from state to state what do these new
uic programs mean for a company like
core wave in terms of raising investment
and how do you think that the
accelerator program can help
european companies like yours so co-wave
is a medical device company involved in
the fight against heart failure
every year millions of hot fellow
patients either die or survive in
trouble condition
and our mission at co-wave is to save
heartfelt patients and offer them
an active life work is based on the
invention of a french engineer who came
up with a disruptive pumping technology
a technology that can change the the
face of cardiac assist
the type of technology that can give
birth to a global leader
but as an entrepreneur i mean there's a
legitimate question is
is europe the right place to to build
such a company indeed in 2020
uh if you look at investment in medical
device
in europe we had like three times lower
investment
than than in three three times lower
investment in in china
and eight times lower investment than in
the u.s and
with eic fund the open commission is
telling entrepreneurs
yes europe is the right place to to uh
to to to build these companies
and in particular for co-wave eic gives
us the mean
to the means to achieve our ambition to
realize our full potential here in
europe to attract
top talents from all continents to
transform our prototypes into an
implantable product
and and ultimately to bring that product
to patients
thank you and since you've actually
received a direct fund from
funding from the eic let me ask you
particularly for a deep tech
company like core wave what's the
difference between taking on eic funding
versus other private investors such as
venture capital or perhaps national
funding programs
so first of all i like to say that
they're complementary in the case of the
crown of co-wave
that co-invested so uh about half of the
funding is coming from
private investors and actually part of
them is as a
private investor and uh the french
hovering bank so they
actually invest together um and the uh
this
you know existing investors from coagula
bringing their
track record of building so successful
uh
products in the field successful
companies in the field so that's very
helpful
then for sure there is a a difference
and in particular there is a different
difference of of scale um eic
fund is way larger than any uh visa fund
in europe and and and therefore they
they you know they
they really have different means and at
this point i don't believe that there is
any
uh investor in europe vc investor that
would have the leeway
to invest 15 million euro in a
preclinical company
as co-wave so that is really um
you know not for in their fitting in
their investment strategy
uh that they keep their larger tickets
for for uh
later stage clinical phase or um or
revenue phase so it's it's really i mean
the eic fund is really filling a gap
here and it's
it's fantastic too to have them on board
wonderful thank you very much well thank
you everyone for joining today
we're now going to move on to the next
session which is specifically about the
eic investing in deep tech
thank you
[Music]
hello and a warm welcome to the launch
event of the european innovation council
my name is obin walters i'm the founding
editor of tech.eu
we're leading news and market
intelligence company focused on the
european innovation industry
today i am very pleased to be joined by
a number of esteemed entrepreneurs and
investors to talk about
the challenges and opportunities of the
deep tech fields in europe
deep tech is one of those terms that
means different things to different
people
but in general the consensus is that it
concerns technologies such as artificial
intelligence semiconductors
robotics self-driving cars blockchain
quantum computing
etc they basically have very deep roots
in science and advanced engineering
in general deep tech takes a relatively
long time to develop and find good
product market fit it's usually more
capital intensive than other types of
digital products and it also has a high
risk of never making it to markets or
finding sufficient commercial traction
when deep tech overcomes those hurdles
however it tends to generate
great rewards breakthrough advancements
in technology and science
that can often have an outsize positive
impacts on the economy
society and humanity as a whole europe
of course has strong roots in science
and engineering are academia world class
and there are reports that should
suggest that european deep tech
companies are worth a combined 700
billion euros today
and counting still there is a lot more
that can be done to unlock the value
that europe's deep talent pool has to
offer
and to make sure that the right
technologies are funded by the right
investors
to bring them to markets on an
international scale
i'm delighted to have a conversation
about this topic uh with hermann hauser
of amadeus capital and of course well
known for his pivotal role at companies
like acorn computers and arm
we have irina javas she is a partner at
leading investment firm atomico
and last but not least veronica udova
she's the co-founder and ceo of life
science company s biomedic
welcome to our panel everyone and please
share with us your insights on how
europe can play a role in the global
deep tech race in the years to come
mr hauser maybe let's start with you are
you optimistic about europe's future in
deep tech
and if so why absolutely but
we also have to acknowledge our place in
the world which is
behind america and increasingly behind
china
so we really have to uh have to up
our game and one of the reasons why
we're so excited about the european
innovation council
is that we do have 10 billion to make a
difference
to the investment environment uh for for
deep tech in europe
because uh europe still only has one
fifth of the venture capital
of america so we need to increase the
amount of money that goes into deep deck
and of course the eic fund is trying to
do exactly that
mr dovah you were the recipient of an
eic grant i believe uh last year
uh maybe share us a little bit more
about uh your journey and your views on
the deep tech space in europe yeah yeah
so for us actually uh we have made quite
interesting experience because with
us biomedic we went a little bit around
the world uh
we actually originated from europe so
i'm from the czech republic my other
co-founder is german and my third
co-founder is spanish
but we actually found our first funding
in chile so we moved the whole project
initially to
uh santiago de chile for seven months
and then from there we were considering
if we should
continue uh down there in latin america
or go to
um to the states where one of my
co-founders was doing his postdoc at
that time in harvard
or if we should go back to europe
eventually we have decided to go back to
europe where we where we have a little
bit of more network
but uh funnily enough also uh the
regulatory uh space was more beneficial
for us to
to establish ourselves in europe and um
yeah despite the fact that the
initial funding is quite difficult to
get
we were able then to leverage the first
european grants which actually got us
over the first
first hurdle and then um right now
for us the location here is is really
given the regulatory landscape and
and the options in the network and the
knowledge that we have also within
belgium
it's um i feel we are really really well
positioned here
great well welcome to europe or welcome
back to europe then um miss haywas
you work for a company that is very
active in investing in deep tech
in europe and beyond uh maybe share with
us your views on on
on the future of deep tech in europe
um i think we're i mean it's interesting
it's an interesting debate what is deep
tag because the technology of today
becomes the mainstream
of tomorrow right at some point cloud
was considered deep tech to some extent
so i don't think this time is different
um
and the essentially the technologies
that are being built and defined as deep
tech
everywhere in the world uh will become
mainstream
mainstream technologies of tomorrow i
think europe has a few
interesting advantages in deep tech um
that may have not
necessarily been there in kind of like
the
internet era for instance um one is the
fact that
the companies tend to be global from day
one so they
serve a global market often um which for
instance if you think about
some of the kind of you know early
internet consumer plays
one of the the challenges in europe has
always been to kind of grow beyond your
local market
and that is not there with deep tech
um the other the other um strong point
of europe is that
we obviously have a lot of strong
universities and
leading universities and therefore ip
coming out of those
um and that's again an opportunity to
to to play um and then the third one i
would say is
this mindset shift from academia to
entrepreneurship
that you see so it used to be that you
know if you were
very good at academically at your phd
wanted to stay in an academic career
path
now increasingly more people that finish
a phd um see entrepreneurship as a real
career option
and part of it is driven by the fact
that some of the costs have gone down
like for instance in
in genetics you can buy a sequencer now
for
you can afford to buy a sequencer while
before it used to be accessible only
in kind of big academic labs or big big
corporate labs so you had to stay in one
of these big institutions to work on
that particular field so there's a few
tailwinds that come from
you know um cost and and access
as well and overall you know i think
europe has an interesting opportunity in
deep tech i think the challenge is more
around
um driving those commercial successes
through
investment there is still there are
still way
less investors in europe um than in the
us especially when it comes to funding
later stage so we come in often at
series a b but when you think about the
later rounds when these companies need
couple of hundred million once they
break through
those are still scarce um in europe and
then
the appetite for taking that sort of
risk on average is is still a little bit
lower i would say
yeah and we'll address that funding up
in a bit more detail
later on as well but you brought me
perfectly to my next question which is
that
all of this deep talent that we have
within academia and science
how can we effectively ensure that that
talent doesn't go lost that we can find
uh commercialization for the ipe that is
being generated in those academia and
also maybe as a follow-up question how
can private investors work together
with the european commission and the eic
for that matter
uh to really unlock the value there uh
maybe mr hauser has some ideas on that
oh sure well that's exactly uh the
reason why the eic
was set up and while we made the rules
of the eic to
make sure that the eic is a catalyst
to crowd in the the market
to crowd in the main bcs in europe
including of course atomico that has
been already uh very supportive of a
number of
eic startups uh in the past
so the way this works is really uh as
everywhere else in the world through an
ecosystem
that consists of the bc the governments
the universities it is just that the
the clusters the the university clusters
the deep tech clusters that exist in the
us
and uh now also in china
uh are still only incipient in europe
um that there are quite a few but they
need to be
supported with a lot more money than
we've had in the past and irena or maybe
already made the very good point that we
actually don't have a start-up problem
in europe
we produce more startups in europe than
the united states few people know this
we have a scale-up problem so the
problem is that once
these startups make it to the tens of
millions
is how can we make sure that they go
then into hundreds of millions and
billions of revenue that's our big
problem
and that's where the eic with 15 million
euros into a single company uh maybe
leveraged by a factor of two or three
uh with uh uh with with the market with
with vcs who put up another
30 or 50 million we get to the 50 to 100
million
uh rounds that are still so rare in
europe
yeah well we have one of the startups uh
that you're
uh talking about on the panel so mr
dovah maybe you can
compliment uh have you had any
conversation with private investors as
you were
developing as biomatic which is of
course heavily rooted in science uh
and how have those conversations been
different from uh from the eic for
example
yeah yeah so we we have indeed we have
an investor experience
for us though was quite important that
we tried to stay quite lean in in the
beginning so we try to actually not not
go for
uh for big investments uh early on and i
think that was also something that irina
mentioned that
uh in europe we have quite good access
already to good technologies to
to relatively uh to a lot of good uh
people
highly educated people which are
compared for example to us
much more affordable um in terms of
salaries and so on
we also heavily took advantage of
incubators so basically we are part of
the johnson and johnson jail ups
incubator
which makes it initially much much
easier to kind of
go over the initial phase um
so we we try to kind of uh yeah stay um
as lean as possible with the with the
investor
investments or with the with the private
funding private money
um but i think yeah we are we're still
relatively early so um
i think we will still come across what
what herman and irina mentioned
um that yeah the bigger bigger amounts
um
how easy or how difficult is it to then
access
we still we still have to make that
experience my
the only the only thing maybe to mention
uh what i see when for example being
exposed towards uh
american startups is that uh they are
quite often despite the fact they don't
have so much data they don't have so
many results they do not have so much
uh technology background they are much
bolder and much more confident to to go
for
uh bigger rounds going um yeah bigger
going uh showing the success
they they have and i think that's
something we still have to learn as
european startups to be a bit more
confident be
bolder and um yeah think think a little
bit bigger
yeah and evidently if you think bigger
you need um
bigger deeper pockets as well irena's
already addressed this as funding up so
i'm going to come back to you
how can we fix that can we really
do something about that in europe to
address that scale-up funding gap
um i mean i think there's
there's a natural evolution of the
ecosystem that will happen
um and we need a few successes for
people to start
actually paying attention um so that's
not something we can do but that's just
kind of a um
a journey we have to take but um
there are of course um you know
initiatives like
like state driven initiatives to back
deep tech company scale ups
or european-wide initiatives are are a
good alternative
um the other um you know the other
option is for european investors to try
and tap earlier into the pockets of like
global investors and just think globally
from
from day one sorry not european
investors european entrepreneurs to
think globally from
from day one because i do think it's
it's a matter of like
showing those successes and then people
will follow
and scale up investors will follow i
think we're already seeing
more a bit more of though of that but
i've
it's not easy to accelerate because it's
not easy to kind of
like all of a sudden start you know five
funds that are all focused on deep tech
scale ups that that doesn't happen
overnight and that doesn't happen
without precedence
so it has to be a combination of non
you know non-private funds i think the
other interesting
um thing that's happening in europe is
that
some of the successful entrepreneurs in
tech so not in
not in deep tech that are
now um you know ipoint or
or essentially have generated enough
wells and are thinking about what are
they going to do
next are building these sort of are
are interested in in deep tech um and
part of it is for
impact for climate for a variety of of
topics and i think one example
is daniel from spotify who's essentially
you know putting one billion of his
own um like net worth into actually
building deep tech companies in europe
it is not scale up it's it's company
building but
it does signal an interest in in the
space
and an acknowledgement of the importance
of
backing some of this innovation
yeah i fully agree there's definitely a
shift of that kind happening
underway in europe right now um mr
hauser you already mentioned this
in the beginning but the eic is
basically coming out of the pilot phase
with about 10 billion euros in funding
is that enough though uh
no it is not and that's uh why it's so
important that the 10 billion
euros is used to crowd in the market
so so far we've actually been doing uh
very well
in that for every one euro that we put
into a company
on average three to five euros come from
the market
so this is actually not the 10 billion a
euro but more like a 30 to 50 billion
euro initiative which which will make a
difference
i mean it is over a seven year period of
course which is the period of uh
horizon europe but it does
of course make the aeic by far the
largest
deep deck fund and that's another reason
why we insisted that
uh more than half of the equity money
has to come from
from the market so that if the eisc
money
acts as a catalyst to crowd in the
market uh
rather than the market having to be
worried that the
eic becomes a dominant player and crowds
them out
so that's why we have the rule that more
than 50 percent of the
money has to come from the market uh bic
has also
started an and very interesting
instrument in my view at least as the
eic fund
i will be investing directly into
startups arena
i don't want to put you on the spot but
uh there's been a lot of talk about you
know
this this dynamic between private
investors and government funding
what's your view on this do you think
they can happily coexist or not
in terms of whether investors would come
and join a
syndicate with government funding or
come after government funding
what specific yes correct do you think
that's a good evolution
or or a bad one for the entrepreneurs
actually
i mean i think like it's not it's not
new that some of our some of our
companies indeed tech do get
grant funding today whether it's from
horizon 2020 or from other sources
it doesn't necessarily happen always in
the same round
syndicate so generally the round we
would
be involved in tends to be a private
round i haven't yet seen
a lot of models where in the same round
you would have a syndicate between
a private and a public investor
uh by public meaning a government body
or uh
something like eic and i cannot answer
that therefore right because i don't
know how
what would be the friction and what
would be the
the admin require i think the only kind
of question i would have
is can these organizations that are
non-private non-funds move fast enough
to to kind of match the realities of how
quickly funding rounds happen because
often
those happen in a couple of weeks and we
have to make decisions very quickly and
therefore the
the barrier is if if you do take much
longer than that to make a decision then
you're just not going to make the
investment but whether they can coexist
on a cap table um
you know in principle it should be
possible but
the devil's in the detail like what are
the requirements what are the
rights in the next round what is the
governance that comes with that funding
and and so on and so forth there's a lot
of models that you can
uh deploy there yeah so they so the eic
of course has has gone out of their way
to to be
vc friendly to be able to make these
decisions fast and also
act in exactly the same way as any other
bc investment with the same rights
the same obligations and no special
deals in terms of
a a government um
uh initiative so so this was one of
those starting points of course of the
eic to
make sure that it does fit uh easily
into the existing cap tables
of of the vc world
great well deep tech in europe um
definitely a topic that i could go on
about for for many hours
uh but unfortunately we're running out
of time veronica i'm going to actually
give you
uh the virtual floor uh just to give
some some closing thoughts as well and
then
we can wrap it up thank you yeah i just
want to quickly follow up on what also
irina said because i have to admit that
uh
first when we when we uh got an
investment from eic in terms of equity
investment
it made us quite nervous exactly for the
reasons how long is it going to take
is it there going to be a fit and so on
i have to say that so far uh we're
making quite a good experience so we're
going for a first half in a convertible
loan second half as a part of the equity
round
and basically through that we we're
going through the through the
due diligence bit earlier with the eic
which then and
i hope will enable us later when we when
we closing the round later this year
that we might be then able to to decide
fast and and be faster
where the eic then um as i understand
will follow basically the lead investor
so uh we will be making this experience
this year but i have to say so far
so far um looks good and and uh looks um
as an important validation
for for our project as well so so far
very happy
great well happiness is very important
and we'll be very
we'll be watching very closely of course
uh what happens thanks for your company
as well
um to everyone thank you so much for
your time we have to wrap up but that
was a very insightful discussion
uh and i think we can be bullish about
the future of deep tech in europe
and hopefully you could all play an
active role in in developing that future
thank you so much for your time and uh
best of luck with everything
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
well good morning everyone i'm really
delighted to welcome you in this third
speed dating exchange with
two great guests jim snever who is
chair siemens uh also works um with
muller
merks and has been a key player in the
eic
advisory board leading us to creating
the ic
and stariana kofteros
who is the vice chair of the cyprus
innovation authority and in this
function also an
angel investor and part of the eic
investment committee so very much
part of making the fun today a success
so welcome to both of you
i'm really delighted to have the
opportunity to
to be part of this conversation as
director general for research and
innovation
i i was involved in in creating the
european innovation council
which holds great promises but also very
concrete results already
after one year and a half of a very
large-scale
pilot so all these we will share with
you
also in this short speed dating exchange
what we will try to explore briefly is
how um the eic
can help innovation ecosystems
to be part and possibly in our
expectation
impactful in europe's green and
digital transformation particularly in
the green transformation as this is
about
sustainability big corporates
public funders are of course very much
strategically investing
in these green transformations but it is
i think very clear that all
technological solutions
but also societal uh developments
are not yet all available to bring
europe to a carbon neutral continent
and even the 55 reduction by 2030 are a
deep challenge
well the eic is about deep tech
innovation
and deep deck certainly is also highly
highly
relevant for these transformations
so that's what we we will now briefly uh
uh explore with uh starting a gym
uh with you if i can so how how do you
see
um the contribution of innovation
ecosystems for a
very large european company like siemens
how do you see that
well thank you very much and good
morning it's an honor for me to be part
of today's
event but also the group that has been
working hard for a couple of years now
it's been
truly inspiring see i'm convinced that
this
next phase of digitization and
disruption
will really focus around industrial
value chains not so much the consumer
toys if i may
anymore and i also believe that we're
moving from what i call
ego systems focusing on capturing value
to ecosystems focusing on
impact impact in particular as you said
on the green agenda
but also around what i call responsible
digitization and that is where siemens
plays today so our interest is genuine
we are in industry value chains and we
have
impact in mind so which are these
ecosystems well
healthcare for instance moving towards
more
individualized therapy and prevention
manufacturing
smart cities mobility and even
energy these are fundamental
infrastructures and industrial value
chains that we need to
dramatically improve and now and now we
can so
what are we looking for at siemens we're
looking for innovative companies
that can help accelerate a future which
is more sustainable
and and what can we provide i think we
provide you know platforms we provide
also global reach
and and one good example you know we
launched an ecosystem around
additive manufacturing where we deliver
a platform and global reach for startups
to really have
more scale in their partnership with
humans
thank you very much jim so indeed
big corporates can help startups
and startups can then also help the
corporates
get to break through ideas and possibly
then also
team up this is also very much as jim i
think you know
what the european innovation council is
already
piloting in corporate days where we we
we connect with these um
a big european corporates and and try to
to do some matchmaking with
the very large number of gtech
innovators which are connected to us
if i move to you uh steph rihanna as as
vice chair of the cyprus
research and innovation foundation you
look at it as an angel investor what are
your expectation
of the eic for cyprus's
innovation capacities and impacts
it's a pleasure to be here in an honor
obviously and it's been a pleasure and
an honor to be involved in the eic ever
since
the very very early on pilots and
amazing to see how it's
uh transforming and taking official
shape
to truly change uh europe because that's
the expectations and by doing that
because everything is about synergy much
like our panel today we have
zimmins a big corporate with uh
myself from a little country like cyprus
from a small ecosystem
europe is so diverse in and and
in everything and that's what exactly
what we need is all the actors
it's the sum of the parts so that we all
play together
in order to scale up europe practically
speaking when when i look at the
robust innovation ecosystem for the
future of europe
99 of that applies for cyprus as well
everything that was identified for
across the ecosystems it applies to
cyprus
with minimum changes and i'm sure it
applies to other countries in that
magnitude as well we need linkages much
like we are here
linkages of a small ecosystem to a
larger ecosystem
linkages of startups and innovative
companies to corporates
access to funding in a way so that we
can create
pipeline for for the eic and for europe
in order to scale because we we need the
numbers it is also a statistics gate
and and indeed i agree with what jim
said it's about
not just the ego and ecosystem totally
agree with you it's time to make an
impact and scale
europe and to do that we need to scale
all the ecosystems
and and create that uh value and impact
locally and european wise
thank you very much i i really like to
this notion of really connecting
uh across uh national research and
innovation systems
and ecosystems and then also uh across
the value chains and
i mean if i move to you jim again uh the
candy i see i mean siemens is is very
much
a large company investing itself and and
on the path
uh on of of its green and digital
transformation
but from that example and many others
which which
which you know how can can you see uh
programs help
these bigger corporates accelerate their
transformation how do you see that
well i think that's a key uh decisive
question
of course and i always argue that
innovation for impact is the combination
of
big ideas so big new ideas multiplied by
the scale so if you have a great idea
and you don't bring it to market
then you don't have impact you just have
a great idea
and and i think you know of course
siemens you know with more than 300
thousand employees
we have kind of both but even as a large
organization with lots of funding
we can see that some of the big ideas we
simply cannot generate
internally and we're humble enough
to realize that this is the case
and that actually means that we are
looking for
you know creative ideas new ideas
breakthroughs
where we instead of you know assuming we
can do it inside
we work with other companies outside and
create ecosystems where we can
add the scalability to those great ideas
we've created an organization called
next 47
which really participates in in
disruption through
supporting some of these startups and
for me the accelerator
is a perfect instrument in the eic to
identify such ideas
and scale them faster and bringing in
large organizations to help scale that
and now you know with those programs
it's become much easier and much faster
but we also need breakthrough
innovations in europe um
quantum computing for instance will be a
huge breakthrough
and again there you know the pathfinder
for me is the perfect example of an
instrument
that addresses exactly that how do we
identify breakthroughs and make sure
that they
actually get the best possible chances
of becoming something meaningful last
week
the european commission launched the
digital compass for europe
and so now is the right moment to
combine
that competes which is really about
let's say
scalable but responsible digitization
and you bring that together with these
instruments of the eic i think we have a
huge opportunity to show the rest
of the world how we can use technology
to make a better future for all which i
think where europe has a
unique cultural heritage
but jim i i would very much uh concur
concur with you on that i think on
science and engineering uh
europe is a powerhouse and indeed the
challenge is to bring these
this disruptive science into uh concrete
ideas and then indeed scaling scale them
up
bring them to the market to to make a
difference the ic had
in this pilot phase 14 000.
one for 14 000 applications
of course not all of them were excellent
but
very many of them were many are not
funded immediately and i think there is
here really a
wealth of great ideas which i hope can
be then picked up
by by great companies in europe
and then really bringing that together i
mean one challenge uh estaria which
which we also have and where
possibly the ic i think can have an
impact
is on the risk aversion of of
private investors i mean my brief tells
me i should say european private
investors but i would say private
investors more generally
with technological startups deep tech
ones particularly
uh do you think the se will make a
difference do you see it already
absolutely yes and that's the big hope
not just you know
to be romantic about it but it is
de-risking
uh earlier on deep tech innovation in a
way that it makes it attractive
the news about the eic fund are
literally music to the ear of the in
the innovation ecosystem across europe
because that would truly
be a catalyst for the risking and kind
of
uh helping with the risk aversion of
european investors when you have an
institutional investor like the eic
going in earlier on it is
as a fact they're risking the situation
and with the support that this companies
receive through the eic accelerator and
the services it creates an
environment that's supporting and more
fertile for them to succeed
at the same time it will also i expect
it will also make a positive impact
where it comes to
shall we say catalyzing m a activity so
big corporates like siemens for example
can get in early on and acquire the
innovation
and the team which is an exit strategy
for startups it exists in other
ecosystems internationally
and we need to get in that game as well
because we are very unique
in europe very engine engineer oriented
we have amazing technology amazing
science and we need that to come into
the market and provide
value to the european citizens by
products by the taxes that the companies
are going to pay because everything
fits in and i think that the eic
is definitely going to well not fingers
crossed because it has shown
the path it's walking and it's it's a
good one that we will be able to realize
that
and and really scale and have an impact
great sabrina thank you very much jim as
well thanks a lot for
for this exchange which i
really i hope gives you a sense of what
the european innovation council will be
doing uh with with all of you which is
connecting connecting science and
innovation
connecting uh this european effort
with very many national
instruments and research and innovation
systems
and then indeed allowing impact to be
achieved
with scaling up we hope fast
and in europe of course scaling up also
by teaming up across europe with
our large engineering and technology
companies these corporates which i have
no doubt will play a major role in
in allowing these very very many
innovators in europe
to to come to to the market and make
their innovations
um impactful so this is um
the perspective the european innovation
council is now launched at scale
uh benefiting from a year and a half of
this very large
pilot but maybe as important as a pilot
benefiting from
the advice of of great innovators
like you jim uh great innovators and
investors like you stephaniana and i
think this is also one
of these the hallmarks of the european
innovation council
benefiting from the wealth of
experience and disruptive
ideas across europe and you're very kind
to make it available to this
european effort on innovation impact
innovations as
our friends in the us would call it but
thank you very much
uh to both of you and i think with that
we conclude
this exchange
[Music]
the european innovation council has been
a great ambition for the commission
over the last two commissions and i'm
really very
delighted to have been able to to help
maria gabriel
and president from the line now really
kick off
the european innovation council so we
heard the president we heard also
commissioner
maria gabriel i was also very pleased to
see that we had
the european parliament with christian
ella
and also the portuguese council
presidency with minister emmanuel
heter this really i hope gave you a
sense that
europeans are very ambitious
on disruptive innovation they
have set the bar i think really high
for the european innovation council
not just to spur
innovation and scaling up but do it with
great impact we have in europe
been traditionally very ambitious on
science and research and
10 years ago we established the european
research council
which i sometimes call europe's noble
price factory
and we are now equally ambitious for
innovation
with the european innovation council
which i personally have
little doubt if i look at the pilot
phase that it will very soon turn into
europe's unicorn factory but as you
could see from the exchanges
in in this short launch event
this is about indeed scaling up but
scaling up
also to make a difference and i think if
you look at
what corporates are are seeing if you
look at what
investors are expecting obviously when
you look at what uh
policy makers are asking the ic to do
i have little doubt that the european
innovation council will help
great ideas to emerge scale up into the
market
but that these ideas would also allow
europe
and possibly beyond to transform
into green societies and green economies
and also in a sustainable digitalization
so that's
what we hope uh for the european
innovation council as you can see the
bar
is very high so i would like to finish
by
wishing all the best to
the teams around the eic of course the
advisory committee
for taking so much of their time to to
help it succeed
and now also the teams in the european
innovation council in the executive
agency which will support
the european innovation council and its
management
uh with jean devine malu leading that
effort to all of you
uh many thanks for the pilot phase and
all the very best
for making this yet another major
european success we will be there with
you thanks to all of you for your
interest
and come to the european innovation
council we are there
to help thank you very much
[Music]
you